all right President Biden's looking to
lay the blame for his border crisis at
Republicans feet and sadly rhinos and
the Senate are more than happy to help
him do it but is it working well we sent
Raymond Royo to the scene where the NYPD
officers were attacked by vicious
migrants to ask Real Americans about who
they think is responsible for this
migrant mess laori it was in front of
this building on 42nd Street where two
cops tried to break up a mob and they
were assaulted by illegal aliens who are
now out Bail free I decided to ask New
Yorkers what should be done and their
reaction to the incident do you blame
President Biden for that I do I do cuz
the wall was being
built then got St honestly I think we
have to protect the Border we need to
know who's here and I'm a DieHard
Democrat and I'm saying that your
thoughts on who's to blame for this
migrant crisis we're seeing in the city
the government you know why the
government is to blame because they let
him in and the only way they can get in
is through the government who do you
blame specifically um Joe Biden why I
blame Joe Biden because Donald Trump
didn't let no migrants in President
Biden why because he's the the the
border is wide open there's a guy named
Joe Biden is that who you blame that's
that's where everything started about
four years ago I blame the White House
they could do a heck of a lot more than
what they're doing to close the border
the governor here says they should be
deported particularly these guys Who
attack the cops do you support deporting
these people if they don't have the
credentials to be able to adapt into
society then Deport them back to where
they belong they need to go back they
need to get deported I mean they're not
here legally we got to deport them we
got to get rid of them but I don't know
how to do it once they get in here so we
got a mess don't we Deport it or yeah
stop allowing them to come to our city
and bringing that they garbage over here
we don't need that we already got our
own system going on people are already
in the shows for 3 4 years it's not fair
they got to leave once somebody else
come from somewhere else all those guys
are out they're 19-year-old Venezuelans
beating the
cops they belong deported into they jail
in
[Music]
Venezuela wow Raymond Royo joins us now
Raymond what was your takeaway here I
mean what didn't we see well I'll tell
you what you didn't see so many people
were afraid to talk Laura they told me
they'd like to say something but felt
they were worried about their jobs they
didn't want to say anything on camera
but there's a lot of fear and a lot of
anger and this cuts across Republicans
Democrats that I spoke to there're you a
lot of the people in that video package
they're not Republicans but they were
deeply upset by the way this is
challenging and draining state and city
resources but the problem is hokel is
saying one thing as you pointed out
earlier in the show and she's doing
another she's granting 4,000 state jobs
Laura to these illegal aliens those are
jobs that could go to to American
citizens and they're going to again get
the shaft for these people that just
arrived and by the way that shelter that
place that I'm standing in front of that
is a shelter on 42nd Street it's between
Madame tusos and where Aladdin is
playing on Broadway but you know what
you don't have to buy a ticket to see a
whole new world it's right there on the
street and it's fights and Drug deals
and things people haven't seen in
decades on 42nd Street now Raymond you
and I have have talked about this off
camera but other than the crime which is
terrible and all that comes along with
it the drugs and all the things that
Donald Trump warned about in 2015 he was
totally right about it also trash which
one of your interviewees referenced
they're bringing their trash she
actually meant physical trash and you
hear that from New Yorkers I see it all
over um uh Northern Virginia Maryland DC
Tires trash mattresses stuff you did not
see in those areas even in suburbs
that's new as well with the migrant you
see these mopeds all around they're
delivering drugs they're delivering food
they're delivering girls I'm told by
some of the cops and this is all
courtesy of the American taxpayer who
are housing these people and in fact New
York state is incentivizing this by now
giving them jobs and shelter so that's
the welcome at no matter what hok is
saying today about deporting these folks
but New Yorkers of one mind on this
regardless of
party and Raymond I think this issue is
one of those issues obviously the
economy important but this issue as you
said cuts across um lines of ethnicity
parties background age I people know
that this is wrong and they're pissed
and I hate that word but they're
community community is falling apart
yeah Raymond excellent work thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling announ is you will
not get it anywhere
else